so why don't you read this one okay
because this is the one this is the one
where i'm like oh man
you kind of practically confirmed it
here
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today so we're doing
a follow up here because some opinions
and thoughts have certainly changed from
what you guys saw in yesterday's video
when we were reacting to those leaked
photos thanks to john campia that went
viral all over twitter because we didn't
know really what to make of it you know
it's like they could be real they could
be fake
okay
maybe they're fake they gotta be fake no
one's getting them like taken down and
that's where we landed on in the real
moment of reacting but i put out a
comment before the video went public
because we shot it the 90 came out and
then i put it up the next morning which
was your yesterday the comment said well
after learning more online about an hour
after filming our reaction let's just
say our opinion towards real or fake has
definitely leaned one way more than the
other bring on the second trailer sony
might as well drop it now uh the reason
i said that is because yeah it would
definitely lead more towards that it's
real
all right we don't have it confirmed for
us directly but it's at a point now
where it's like seems practically
confirmed to say confirmed would be
someone from sony marvel or someone who
were publicly on the movie would have to
come out and directly say it but
there's just far too much evidence
especially when it lines up with some
things that sir john campio said during
his own live stream so what i want to do
is kind of go through why we are
convinced that it's probably real
obviously no one from any studio or
something has confirmed this for us
that's an impossible from evidence
gathered from uh some photos that seem
to sync it up and then also uh some
things in jaw campious in his own
follow-up live stream addressing this a
in that hour after getting the video
prepped to go up in the morning a lot of
leakers were saying it's real that's the
way it goes right leakers scoopers it's
real but then there are all these photos
breaking it all down involving like tom
hall and shoes the bruises scarring on
tom holland's face matching up with
other photos that were publicly released
the bar that andrew garfield was holding
on to and the famous on not the werewolf
moment you know the floor that the
spiderman were standing on the living
room setting and it was like yep that's
definitely this is this got to be real
right i mean
too much it shares with a bunch of other
imagery i've seen from the movie yeah
yeah i want to go through some quotes
from campia's stream you guys can watch
john camp yesterday it's it's really
it's entertaining i i actually i'm
friends with the guy i like his show a
lot and whenever i guest start on it
it's always like a highlight for me so i
personally really like campy he's always
been extremely extremely nice to me and
helpful in in more ways than one and i
really like a show too but let's uh
let's let's do some pull codes on the
guy when i'm under the spotlight we're
not gonna go through everything you said
but it's like all right time to play
some detective work you want to talk
about fair game on your stream well now
some of the quotes you have are fair
game too okay so the first thing john
you want to read it i post it and five
minutes later i get a call from somebody
i won't say who saying that yeah uh
these pictures are probably real i'm
like are you sure and like
uh look i don't know
a hundred percent for sure but i feel
comfortable saying that these are all
most likely real and i'm like well [ __ ]
so i immediately jumped back on twitter
again only about five minutes had passed
and i delete them immediately
already who called him he will not
reveal who his source is that's a good
man right there
no matter what
heaven himself it gets a tad bit more
juicy i'm not talking about how we
talked about toby maguire's crotch
look closely at toby mcguire's dick
that's a whole separate video that's a
whole separate video we're gonna do
tomorrow
actually if the studios wanted him to
reveal who his source was that gave him
the photo just that inquiry alone is an
indication that perhaps it is indeed
real he goes on to say there were more
pictures there were more than the two i
put up there were indeed i want to say
four and i was going to post those other
pictures as well i was going to wait
another five minutes and then post the
other picture i obviously didn't share
the other two pictures and the other two
pictures are the more juicy ones that's
all i'm going to tell you is that the
other two pictures were the more juicy
ones but then now that i know there's a
strong possibility that they're real i'm
not going to be posting those i love
that he said that
because he's just sitting on this
treasure trove
now all those scoopers and leakers are
gonna go how do we hack this guy's
emails
we're breaking his phone his computer
everything i want those two pictures on
my desk tonight but here's the big one
this is the most telling thing he said
personally because he talks a lot but
this is the one where i'm like oh man
you kind of practically confirmed it
here and actually did you watch this
stream i caught some of it but about the
time i was getting to the spider-man
stuff we had to hop into filming
this is still pretty fresh to me so why
don't you read this one okay because
this is the one where i'm like dude
good i'm excited dude i was talking to
one of the studio reps sorry whenever i
read campy i just have to go into his
cadence of course i get it i'll say
studio that has a letter s in it
and they basically marveled
marvel studios two s's
so they basically said to me like i
assume you thought these things were
fake because you put your watermark on
it i don't expect that you would try to
steal the mona lisa and leave your
business card behind for the cops to
call you and i'm like
yes if i thought they were real and i
was going to share them online i would
absolutely not put my watermark on it so
everybody knew the leak came from me
come on
wow
wow
i mean yes that would be the dumbest
that means the dumbest especially with
how well ingrained with you know campy's
got good relationships with the studios
and that's a one-way ticket to not that
he heavily stressed this during the
stream and i full-heartedly believe him
i haven't talked to him at all about
this situation i'm gonna say that i've
talked a bit all about this i do firmly
believe that he does not he's not a big
fan of leaks whatsoever once in a while
he gets things spoiled for him this is
the first time i can recall where he's
really ever been associated with the
leak maybe i'm wrong about that we know
the circle you know the grace daniel
rpk's the big screen leaks you know
there's a big much different community
of scoopers and leakers and he's not
really that guy i do believe he was
genuine and stating that he did not
think that they were real and that's why
he was like screw it up because he had
another photo that got like 12 000
retweets got a lot of followers and the
photo blew up he was a photoshop one so
he put his name on his watermark on it
because he was like well he knows a cool
photo so if it gets bigger i want people
to know like where it came from yeah and
i believe him because he's not the kind
of guy who would just leak that
especially with the reputation clout
that he has with studios and the
relationships that he has i believe that
however dude you said
the letter s
sony that's where your mind is likely to
go duke maybe he's talking about studios
if the analogy is to be held true that
this person was saying i assume you
thought these things were fake because
you put the watermark on it if that's
the way it's being communicated to him i
assumed you thought they were fake that
inherently implies that they're real but
you thought they were fake yeah and we
have control over we have the right to
these images and we're giving you the
benefit of the doubt exactly and then to
say i don't expect that you would try to
steal the mona lisa mona lisa being this
is the sony person
being the one referring to the photos is
the mona lisa and then leave your
business card honor for the cops to call
you and then you're saying your response
if i had thought they were real and i
was going to share them online i would
absolutely not put my watermark on it so
everybody knew the leak came from me i
would just put it on my twitter account
yeah exactly to me this specific
paragraph yeah is the part where i'm
like well you got a call from the studio
you got kaufman or you call the student
and they talk to you about it there's a
reason you couldn't reshow them again on
your own personal live stream which i
totally understand because they got to
be real
and this whole statement right here is
just that's the most indicative part i
mean if it was nothing no one would call
you yeah this is just some fan made
photoshop i think they would just let
that further perpetuate the advertising
that this all exactly so guys yeah
between all the correlations that people
were able to do with piecing together
with other photos john put out some
tweets yesterday that are now no longer
up he further elaborates here and i'm
like oh no no no that just sounds like
it's you definitely gotta call cause
you're real now
not confirmed yet for all we know still
could be fake for all we know i'm just
saying i
don't think they are real yeah it seems
like for this much hubbub to be caused
over them and for as many people to be
like can we share these or not there's
definitely fire where that smoke is
coming from all right guys well do you
want to celebrate with the
99.9 percent chances
are you spoil are you set to be spoiled
potentially yeah i mean if you're again
if you came across it on twitter but if
you're clicking on this video don't be
that guy you already knew all right guys
well subscribe click the notification
bell hit the like button and hey we will
catch you guys soon and subscribe to
john can't be his channel man he's a
great guy it's got a great show